this is gonna sound stupid but usually
when I tell people I have five cats I
get this reaction Wow five cats that's
crazy
I've come to enjoy this reaction I
expect nothing less than this reaction
unless you like a fellow cat lady with a
comparable amount of cats in which case
we shall bond for life but when I was at
a party and I told someone I had five
cats and they said Wow five cats I mean
that's much less than Bella Thorne she's
got like 19 he's pretty pissed I mean
immediately my five cats paled in
comparison and I started to wonder
should I get 15 more I mean this is
unacceptable people are gonna think that
I'm not serious about pants like I told
you it sounds stupid but I use this
analogy because it also sounds stupid
when a friend says so I got a promotion
oh I'm so jealous of you your success
makes me feel like a failure and I wish
you would just stop crying in a
professional or personal capacity
because it makes me feel insecure
now it's natural for us to feel Envy
when someone else succeeds but the
important thing is if you're using that
Envy to serve you or if you're using it
to self criticize for example if I look
at a picture of a delicious gluteus
maximus and I feel jelly I can react one
of two ways the first way oh my god this
girl is so conceited all she cares about
is showing off her body like yeah we get
it you go to the gym or oh my god Becky
look at this but it is so muscular I
mean she must have done like thousands
and thousands of squats this is what
hard work looks like this is what
happens when you stick to your glutes oh
my god I am just I'm so inspired by this
I have to print it for my vision board
so whenever I feel jealous of someone
else's success or body or intelligence I
remind myself what reaction is gonna
help me achieve what I want
internalizing this envy as insecurity or
as inspiration and I don't know about
you but I like feeling inspired a hell
of a lot more than I do feeling insecure
and what's wonderful is that when you do
feel inspired by someone else's success
the next natural question is well how do
they get there
what can I do that they did to get where
they are versus if you let your jealousy
fester into resentment yeah whatever I'm
sure she just got lucky or headlight
connections or something you dismiss
their success without ever exploring the
methods of how they achieved it so when
you feel jealous and we all do you have
a choice you can let that jealousy make
you feel like you're not good enough or
you can turn it into ambition and I
think it's pretty obvious which path is
gonna help you get to the same level of
success that will in turn inspire
jealousy and others I'm Anna Akana and
I'm gonna get every cat in the world I
would like to say thank you to full Lane
for sponsoring today's video fellahin is
a clean beauty retailer that has
incredibly safe products there are a
hundred percent non-toxic vegan and
cruelty-free
I love them I'm a health nut about what
I eat making sure I get enough exercise
and sleep and of course the products
that I put on my skin and the main actor
but for real our skin is our largest
organ absorbing up to 60% of the
products that we put on it which is why
every product on fileting shelf goes
through a rigorous five-step approval
process the complete opposite of how I
choose my partners they're clean
essentials kit is the most adorable and
practical thing that I now own for
traveling and it's already tsa approved
thank God it comes with a cleanser a
toner a moisturizer and this adorable
cute soap that you can literally use on
anything all in this adorable emerald
pouch the kit is usually $45 but the
first hundred people to click on the
link in the description will get 50% off
and free delivery making it only $22
Thank You filleting for clean beauty me
and musk and appreciate you
you